THE PLACE WHERE HE PLAYED 15
SEASONS BUT IF YOU PODKOLZIN NOG
IN TO TAKE THE FACE-OFF HERE.PO.
BROWN NOW WITH THER PROFESSIONAE
AGE OF 37, I MEAN HIST ROY, TRYR
ONE.
DEFLECTED, THEN
SEAN DURZI. GET THAT
ONE THROUGH AGAIN.
THAT TIME, BLOCKED. BOUNCING WIH
HORVAT AFTER THAT PUCK. THE SEAG
IT O O THE FIRST
PERIOD.
A GAME THAT STARTED SCRAMBLY BUT
ID HE HEAD UPI
PRACTICE ON THURSDAY AND THEN
ANOTHER GAME.
>> John S.: THE SECOND UNIT IS
OUT AS MILLER HAS REACTION, GIVS
TENDER A LITTLE TAP  IS VIKTOR S
TIME.
TO THE SIDE AND THAT ONE-TIMER S
HÖGLANDER AND THEN IT IS
THATCHER DEMKO BUT HE COULD NOT
COVER THE PUCK AND THE THE TIME.
AND IT ISG.: WHAT PUCK MOVE
MEMPHIS AND VERY GOOD CHEMISTRY
HERE, THE THREE OF THEM, HOW
MUCHING THAT
THAT PUCK, SHOT IN BY MOORE.
BACK TO GET IT, LUKENG THAT
PUCK TO THE MIDDLE AND THEY ICE
THE PUCK NOW WITH AOVE AT THE CD
úHUGHES.úGARLANDúDOWN LOW.úCHAID
PERIOD WITH PODKOLZIN RUSHING
IN.
HE HAD THE ONLY NOW TO MOORE WIH
FOUR KINGS ON THE RUSH AS THE
CANUCKS LOOK TO HUSTLE
COUPLE AND OKPOSO LAMMIKKO.
DOWN TO LESS THAN 10 TO G G
IT IS A PENALTY SHOT FOR
STOPPE.
SEASON THE CANUCKS AREINN
HUGHES.
A LEAD FEED.O
PODKOLZIN, LIFTING THAT HIGH ONE
IN OFF OF THE END BOARDS WITH
THAT PUCK THE VANCOUVER
END.
EKMAN-LARSSON, TO MYERS, BANKING
WHISTLE.TO
>> John G.: OH, BOY, KEMPE
COMING
PUCK INTO THE CORNER.
HE GOT A A LINEUP UNDER HIS
PICKED THAT PUCK
CLEANLY AND NOWHORVAT AT THE
BLUE LINE.
THE PUCK, IT COMES AROUND,
DISCOMFORT HERE.